The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Hi.
In this lecture,
there are two sets
of ideas that I'd like
to discuss, both of which
are related to our topic of the
last several lectures, namely,
the Z-transform.
The first topic that
we will focus on
is what I'll referred to as
the geometric interpretation
of the frequency response.
Now, you recall that in
lecture 5 when I introduced
the Z-transform, we
observed the relationship
between the Z-transform
and the Fourier transform.
The notion behind the geometric
interpretation of the frequency
response is to relate, in
terms of a geometric picture,
the rough characteristics of the
frequency response of a system
and the pole-zero pattern
for the system function
for the system.
The second topic that we'll
focus on and eventually tie
back into this
geometric interpretation
is the general issue of
some of the properties
of the Z-transform.
And we'll illustrate
some of these properties
with some examples.
But first of all, let's
turn our attention
to the subject of the geometric
interpretation of the frequency
response.
And let me begin
by reminding you
of one of the important
properties of the Z-transform
for a linear shift invariant
system, namely the fact
that if we have a linear shift
invariant system with a unit
sample response, H of n, input
x of n, and output y of n,
then of course, y of n is
the convolution of H of n
with x of n.
And the Z-transform
of the output
is the product of the
Z-transform of the input
and H of Z, the Z-transform of
the unit sample response, which
is what we've been referring
to as the system function.
And in first developing
the Z-transform,
we tie together the notion of
the Z-transform and the Fourier
transform, in particular,
the important interpretation
that the Fourier transform
is the Z-transform evaluated
on the unit circle.
So in terms of the
system function H of z,
if we evaluate that
on the unit circle
for z equal to e to
the j omega, the result
is the frequency response of the
system, H of e to the j omega.
Simply a statement
that the Z-transform
evaluated on the unit circle
is the frequency response
of the system.
Well, in terms of
a simple example,
we drag out our
usual simple example.
The system function is 1 over
1 minus az to the minus 1 or z
divided by z minus a.
And in terms of the z
plane representation,
or pole-zero representation
in the z-plane,
we then have a representation of
this rational function in terms
of one pole--
the pole at z equals a--
and one zero, that is
the zero at z equals 0.
Well, to get the frequency
response associated
with that system
function, we want
to look at the Z-transform
evaluated on the unit circle.
We can do that geometrically
by interpreting
this complex number as
a vector in the z plane
and this complex number as a
vector in the z plane, in which
case the magnitude
of H of z will
be the ratio of the
magnitudes of those vectors.
And the angle of H of z will
be the angle of this vector
minus the angle of this vector.
In other words, suppose that
we want to look at H of z,
at some value of z.
And let's say, for the moment,
not on the unit circle,
or it could be on
the unit circle.
Let's just pick a general
value z equals z1.
We have a vector corresponding
to this complex number, which
is the vector, or
complex number, z.
And that's a vector going from
the origin out to this point.
We have one vector, which
is the vector z or z1
because we're evaluating
this at z equals z1.
So this is a vector z1.
And the vector z corresponding
to the complex number z minus a
is the vector z or z1
minus the vector a.
The vector z1 is this vector.
The vector minus
a is this vector.
And the sum of those
two, the vector
that corresponds to the
complex number z minus a,
is the vector whose
tail is at this pole
and whose head is at the
value of z, at which we
want to evaluate H of z.
And so we end up then
with an interpretation
of the value of H
of z in polar form
with its magnitude
equal to the magnitude
of this vector divided by the
magnitude or length of the pole
vector.
And the angle of this
complex number, H of z at z
equals z1 is the
angle of the 0 vector
minus the angle of
the pole vector.
That's a general statement.
And z1 can be any
place in the z plane.
So we have then the statement
as I've just made it,
which we would now like to
apply to the interpretation
or the generation of the
frequency response of a system.
So we have, then, our example
that is one pole at equals a
and 0 at z equals 0.
We have the 0 vector
and the pole vector.
And as we generate the
frequency response for z1
equal to e to the j
omega, we have the point
on the unit circle at
which we're evaluating
the Z-transform changing.
If we think of angular
distance around the unit circle
as omega, then as
omega varies and we
consider the relative behavior
of these two vectors, what
we essentially trace
out is the frequency
response of the system.
So let's look at this and for
this example see if we can get,
for this example, a rough
idea of what the frequency
response should look like.
Well, first of all we observe.
And this is an important
observation, since it's
a point that comes
up frequently,
is that as we travel
around the unit
circle, the vector from
the 0 to the unit circle
changes in angle, of course.
But it doesn't change in length.
The 0 vector for this
example, or in fact
any vector from the origin
out to the unit circle,
as we vary omega and, therefore,
trace around the unit circle,
this vector doesn't
change in length.
So if we're interested in, say,
the magnitude of the frequency
response, any poles or zeros
at the origin, of course,
have no effect on the magnitude.
The only effect
that they have is
on the phase of the
frequency response
that is on the angle of H of z.
And in fact, as we sweep
around the unit circle,
what happens to this angle?
Well, that angle is just
simply equal to the value omega
that we're looking at that
is the frequency value omega.
So then, in fact, poles or zeros
at the origin as, of course,
we could see from a
strictly algebraic argument.
But from a geometric
argument, it
should be clear that poles or
zeros at the origin introduce,
in the frequency response,
a linear phase term.
And they have no
effect on the magnitude
since the length of a vector
from the origin to the unit
circle is obviously 1.
As a consequence of
that, by the way,
often when talking about
the frequency response
or equivalently when looking
at pole-zero patterns,
it's common to
minimize or ignore
the presence of zeros
or poles at the origin
since they just correspond
to a linear phase term.
Now, let's look at what the
behavior of the pole vector is.
The pole vector as we start,
say, at omega equals 0,
we have a vector
going from the pole
to this point on
the unit circle.
And as we sweep
around in frequency
until we get to omega equals pi
halfway around the unit circle,
the length of this vector
is monotonically increasing.
Well, what does that mean about
the magnitude of the frequency
response?
It means that the magnitude
of the frequency response,
which should be the
magnitude of that vector--
the magnitude of the
frequency response
is monotonically decreasing
as we sweep from omega
equals zero around
to omega equals pi.
At omega equal to pi, we have
exactly the reverse situation.
The length of the
vector from the pole--
and let me draw that vector--
from the pole to
omega equals pi as we
sweep around back
to omega equals
0, the length of that
vector decreases.
So the magnitude of the
frequency response increases.
So for this particular
example, by just observing
what happens to the
length of this pole vector
as we trace around
the unit circle,
we can see that the frequency
response starts at some value.
That's obvious.
And as it sweeps around to pi,
it monotonically decreases.
And when we come back
from pi around to 0,
the frequency response
increases again.
And I don't know if I've drawn
it so that it looks clearly
this way.
But in fact, this piece is
just this piece reflected over.
There's another
important point that we
can observe geometrically.
It's a point about the frequency
response that, of course,
we've emphasized several
times in several ways.
This just offers an
opportunity to re-emphasise it
in yet another way.
As the frequency variable
goes from 0 around to 2pi,
we trace out a
magnitude and then,
of course, also a phase
for the frequency response.
When we get back to 0 or 2pi,
if we go from 2pi around to 4pi,
what should we see for
the frequency response?
Well, we should see
exactly the same thing
that we saw before because
what we're doing literally,
actually, is going
around in circles.
We started here, went
around there to get
the 2pi, omega equals 2pi.
For omega from 2pi to
4pi, we go around again.
For 4pi to 6pi, we go
around again, et cetera.
So just geometrically
by looking at
this geometric interpretation
of the frequency response,
it gives us an
opportunity to emphasize
once again that the frequency
response is a periodic function
of frequency.
Now, this is for one
specific example.
The more general
statement, then,
is that the magnitude of
the frequency response
is equal to the product of
the length of the 0 vectors--
the vectors from the
zeros to the unit circle--
divided by the product of the
length of the pole vectors--
the vectors from the
poles to the unit circle.
And the angle of the
frequency response
is the sum of the
angles of the 0 vectors
minus the sum of the
angles of the pole vectors.
Incidentally, it usually is
the case-- or it is for me,
anyway--
that often, it's possible to
get a rough picture of what
the magnitude of the
frequency response
is like by looking at
this geometric picture.
It's usually somewhat more
difficult except, perhaps,
for linear phase
terms, et cetera,
to get a very clear picture
of what the phase looks like.
Well let's just look at
one more example, which
is a kind of example that we
haven't discussed explicitly
up to this point.
And this also provides
us with an opportunity
to introduce this idea.
Let's consider the
case of a Z-transform
which has a pole-zero
pattern consisting
of a pair of complex conjugate
poles in the z-plane.
These are complex
conjugate poles
with a radius equal
to some value,
say r, and an angular
spacing equal to omega 0.
So this pole is at omega 0.
This pole is at an
angle of minus omega 0.
And using this notion of
interpreting the frequency
response geometrically,
let's just sketch out
roughly what we would
expect the frequency
response to look like.
Well, let's see.
If we start at
omega equals zero,
then we have a
vector from this pole
and a vector from this pole.
The resulting value of
the frequency response
is 1 over the product
of those two vectors.
As we move around the unit
circle from omega equals 0,
let's say, to some point
that's closer to omega 0,
then this vector gets
changed to that one.
And this vector gets
changed to this one.
Well, we can see what's
happening to the vector
lengths.
This vector is getting
shorter as we approach
omega equal to omega 0.
This vector is getting longer.
But you can imagine-- and I
think it should be relatively
clear from the picture--
that this vector is getting
shorter faster than this one
is getting longer.
It seems relatively clear
from a geometric picture
that the product of the
lengths of these two vectors
is smaller when omega is closer
to omega 0 than, let's say,
when omega is equal to 0.
So consequently, we would expect
the magnitude of the frequency
response to start at some value.
As we get in the vicinity
of omega equal to omega 0,
we would expect that
frequency response to peak.
As we pass that pole,
the frequency response
will now begin to decrease.
And clearly, when we are
at omega equal to pi,
the product of the lengths
of these two vectors
is considerably longer
than the products
of the lengths of the
vectors at omega equals 0.
So on the basis
of that argument,
we can see that roughly
what we expect the frequency
response to do is
begin at some value,
increase as we approach the
pole at omega equals omega 0,
decrease as we pass the
pole heading toward pi.
And then from pi around to
pi, or equivalently from 0
around to minus pi, we would
expect the reciprocal behavior.
That is, the frequency
response would increase,
peak in the vicinity of
this pole in the lower
half of the z-plane, and
then return to the same value
that it started from.
And of course, it'll
be periodic as we
run around the unit circle.
Well, this is a
resonant characteristic,
reminiscent in the analog
case of what we would expect
from a complex conjugate
pole pair close to the j
omega axis that's
in the s-plane.
And in fact, of
course, in the s-plane,
we have exactly the same
kinds of geometrical arguments
to allow us to roughly sketch
out the frequency response.
The only real
important difference
is that in the
discrete time case,
it's the unit circle, which
is the locus in the z-plane
that we're looking at.
In the continuous
time case, it's
the vertical, or j omega
axis in the s-plane
that we're looking at.
Well, this shouldn't be
particularly evident from what
we've done here.
But by inference or by
carrying your intuition
from the continuous time
to the discrete time,
can you guess at what you
would expect the unit sample
response of a system with this
pole-zero pattern to look like?
Well, it would look
like the discrete time
counterpart of what happens
in the continuous time case.
That is, it would look like
a damped sinusoidal sequence
with the damping influenced
by the distance of these poles
from the unit circle.
The closer the pole
is to the unit circle,
the sharper this
resonant peak will
be and the less damping
on the sinusoid.
One additional point
to remind you of--
I made reference to this
in an earlier lecture.
But notice that in talking
about the Z-transform poles
and zeros, et cetera
here, I didn't say what
the region of convergence was.
Or at least, I
didn't say explicitly
what the region of
convergence was.
But did I say
implicitly what it is?
Well, sure I did because what I
said or what I've been assuming
is that the systems that
we've been talking about
can be described in terms
of a frequency response.
In other words, the
unit sample response
has a Fourier transform.
Well for that to be the case,
the region of convergence
has to include the unit circle.
And then, we can use
all those other rules
of regions of convergences
to allow us to figure out
from there how far on both
sides of the unit circle
the region of
convergence extends.
All right, well this is, then,
a geometrical interpretation
of the frequency response.
It's often useful
as a rough guide
in getting a general picture
of what the frequency
response might look like.
Although, for complicated
cases, it's often
difficult to get precise
details about the frequency
response, which of course, we
could also get algebraically.
Well now, I'd like to,
at least temporarily,
change gears or topics and talk
about the issue of properties
of the Z-transform in
talking about the properties
and working some
examples to illustrate
the use of the properties
of the Z-transform.
In fact, I'll have occasion
to make reference back
to this geometric interpretation
of the frequency response
to help with at least
one of the examples.
So now I'd like to turn
our attention, then,
to the question or the
topic of the properties
of the Z-transform.
Well, first of
all, why do we want
properties of the Z-transform?
The Z-transform has properties.
Why do we want these properties?
One of the reasons--
it's a very practical reason--
is that the properties
of the Z-transform
help us in calculating
Z-transforms and inverse
Z-transforms.
And they also, obviously,
provide a certain amount
of intuition and
insight with regard
to generally dealing
with Z-transforms
and their inverses.
Well, there are a
lot of properties.
In fact, there are
trivial properties.
There are very
complicated properties.
There are properties
that we more commonly
tend to carry around.
And I've listed a few that
shouldn't be considered
to be exhaustive
but generally tend
to be the properties that
turn out to be the handiest.
That is, these are
the properties,
at a minimum, that you
should carry around
in your back pocket.
Well, let's see.
We're talking about a sequence,
x of n with a Z-transform,
x of z.
One of the properties that
we've taken advantage of already
throughout the entire
discussion of the Z-transform
is the fact that
the Z-transform maps
convolution to multiplication.
If I have the convolution
of two sequences,
then the resulting
Z-transform is the product
of the Z-transforms.
The second property, which
is often very useful,
is referred to as the shifting
property, which says that if I
shift x of n by an amount n0--
and you should think, by the
way, of if n0 is positive,
does that mean shifting to the
right or shifting to the left?
Well, I'll let you
think about that.
It's something that
you should nail down.
If I shift the sequence x of n
by replacing the argument by n
plus n0, then the
resulting Z-transform
is z to the n0 times x of z.
That is, shifting corresponds
to multiplying by z to the n0.
Another useful property has
to do with taking a sequence
and turning it around in n.
That is, replacing n by minus n.
The resulting effect
on the Z-transform
is to replace z by 1 over z.
Another useful
property is the result
of multiplying a sequence x of
n by an exponential, a to the n.
a might be complex.
Or it might be real.
And the result there is that
the z transform is x of 8
to the minus 1 times z.
Another one which is
useful is multiplication
of a sequence by n which
results in a z transform, which
is minus z times the
derivative of x of z.
And then I've indicated--
tried to be somewhat explicit--
that that's not the
end of the list.
There are lots of
other properties--
a number of others that
are presented in the text,
others besides that that aren't
presented in the text, ones
that you can dream up yourself,
ones that your friends
know that you don't, et cetera.
Now, we could, of course, go
through the proof of all these.
The proofs of
properties tend to all
be in somewhat of a similar
vein, as a matter of fact.
And the style, once you see
what the trick is or roughly
how you go about
proving properties,
then you can just
prove properties
and prove properties.
And we won't do that
in this lecture,
with the exception
of illustrating
the style of proving properties
with a couple of examples.
And the two examples that I've
picked, somewhat arbitrarily
as a matter of fact, is
the Shifting Property,
that is Property 2, and the
result of multiplication
by an exponential,
which is Property 4.
But this is only to
illustrate the style
of proving properties.
And you can guess
where, actually, you
get a chance to see the
proof of some of the others.
All right, let's take
a look at Property 2,
that is the Shifting Property.
Well, to prove that
replacing n by n plus n0
results in z to the
n0 times x of z,
we want to consider a sequence,
x1 of n equal to x of n plus n0
so that its
Z-transform, x1 of z,
is the sum of x of n plus
n0 times z to the minus n.
Well, a simple idea here is
a substitution of variables.
Let's replace n plus n0
by a new variable, m, or n
is equal to m minus
n0, in which case,
we can rewrite this
expression as x1 of z
is the sum on m of x of
m, because this is now m.
n is replaced by m minus n0.
So we have z to the n0
times z to the minus m.
Well, the z to the n0
can come outside the sum.
The limits on the
sum, incidentally,
are m equals minus
infinity to plus infinity
because if n0 is finite, as
n runs from minus infinity
to plus infinity, so does m.
That comes outside the sum.
And what's left, then, is the
sum of x of m z to the minus m,
which is just x of z.
So consequently, then, what
we end up with is that x of z
is z to the n0 times x of z.
x1 of z is z to the
n0 times x of z,
which is, of course,
the way I advertised.
Well, there are lots of times
when, in fact, the Shifting
Property comes into play.
One thing that we can
use it for immediately
is to tie together
a couple of things
that have been floating, more
or less, in the background.
I have alluded several
times to the fact
that systems whose system
function is rational
correspond to systems
that are characterized
by linear constant coefficient
difference equations.
That is, linear constant
coefficient difference
equations, those
are the systems that
end up with system functions
that are rational functions.
And in fact, we can see that
in a straightforward way
by just simply applying
the Shifting Property.
Well, let's consider a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation of the general form is
the sum from k equals 0 to n.
a sub k y of n minus k is equal
to a sum of b sub k times x
of n minus k.
If we take the Z-transform of
both sides of this equation
and use the fact-- incidentally,
this is another property
that I've more or
less been using,
although I've never
stated explicitly--
that the Z-transform of a sum
is the sum of the Z-transforms.
Taking, then, the
Z-transform of this equation,
y of n minus k using
the Shifting Property
will give us z to the
minus k times y of z.
And x of n minus k will give us
z to the minus k times x of z.
Consequently, the sum of a
sub k z to the minus k y of z
is equal to the sum of b sub
k z to the minus k x of z.
If we solve that
equation for y of z
over x of z, which is
the system function,
then we end up with
the sum of b sub k z
to the minus k divided by
the sum of a sub k times z
to the minus k.
And there are a couple of
important observations.
One is we ended up with a
rational function, which
is what we expected, or what
I said we were going to get.
And a second is that the
coefficients in the numerator
polynomial are exactly the
same as the coefficients
on the right hand side of
the difference equation.
And the coefficients in
the denominator polynomial
are exactly the same as the
coefficients on the left hand
side of the difference equation.
This by the way, is exactly
consistent, or analogous,
with what happens when we
apply the Laplace transform
to linear constant coefficient
differential equation.
Exactly the same thing happens.
It should be clear
then, incidentally,
that if I give you a
system function that's
a rational function of z,
that you could construct,
in a straightforward way,
the difference equation that
characterizes that
system because you
can pick the coefficients
off from the numerator.
Those are on the
right hand side.
And you can pick
the coefficients off
from the denominator.
Those are on the left hand side
of the difference equation.
The Shifting Property is a
property that arises very often
and, in fact, is a very,
very useful property.
Now, the second property that
I want to outline the proof for
is the property related to
multiplication of the sequence
by an exponential a to the n.
I am forming a new sequence x1
of n, which is a to the n times
x of n.
And to derive the relationship
between x1 of z and x of n,
again, we can look at
the Z-transform, x1 of z,
which is the sum of a to the n,
x of n, times z to the minus n.
Well, it's
straightforward to rewrite
what's inside the sum as x of
n times a to the minus 1 times
z to the minus n.
x1 of z is the sum of x of
n times a to the minus 1z--
all that raised to the minus n.
Well, that looks just like
the Z-transform of x of n
but with z replaced by a
to the minus 1 times z.
So this says, consequently,
that the Z-transform of x1 of n
is equal to the
Z-transform of x of n
but with z replaced by a
to the minus 1 times z.
So we stick in here a
And that then relates
the Z-transform
of the original sequence
and the Z-transform
of the sequence multiplied
by a decaying exponential.
Well, it's interesting to look
at what this property implies
in terms of the movement of the
poles and zeros in the z-plane.
That is, a useful
notion or a useful fact
to have, again, stored
away in your hip pocket
is the effect on the poles
and zeros of a system function
or a Z-transform of
multiplying the sequence
by an exponential-- maybe
a complex exponential,
maybe a real exponential.
Well, let's focus
on a pole or a 0.
And the result that
we get by considering
just a simple pole
or 0 will, of course,
generalize to all
the poles and zeros.
So let's consider x
of z to have a factor
either in the numerator
and denominator of the form
z minus z0.
Well, x1 of z will
then have a factor
derived from that one, but
for which z is replaced
by 8 to the minus 1 times z.
And then we have the minus z0.
Or if we pull the a
to the minus outside,
we have a to the minus 1
times z minus a times z0.
So there are two effects here.
One effect-- if we think of x of
z as a product of zeros divided
by a product of poles--
one effect is that there
is a constant that,
perhaps, collects out in front.
But we never see that constant
anyway in the pole-0 pattern.
The more important point
is that whereas here we
had, say, 0 at z equals z0, that
0 is now shifted to a times z0.
So the 0 at z0 gets replaced
by a 0 at eight times z0.
A pole at z0 gets replaced
by a pole at a times z0.
Well, more specifically,
then, here's
our polar 0 which gets converted
to that polar 0 multiplied
by a.
And if we write
this or think of it
in polar form, as r0
e to the j theta 0,
then the result is a times
r0 times e to the j theta 0.
Well obviously then, if this
number a is a real number,
then the only effect on
the location of the pole
is to change its radial value
and not change its angle.
More generally, if a is complex,
then to write the resulting
polar zero in polar
form, we would
replace this by its magnitude
and add to the phase--
the phase that corresponds
to that number a.
Well consequently, first of
all, if a is real and positive,
actually, if a is real
and positive, then
if we had a pole
of x of n say here,
here being any place,
then if a is real,
what happens to that pole is
that it moves either in or out.
But it moves radially as
we vary the value of a.
So that's for a real.
What's the movement of the
pole if a is pure imaginary?
Well, if a is pure imaginary,
then the magnitude of a is--
I'm sorry.
Not if a is pure imaginary,
but if the magnitude of a
is equal to 1 and it has only
a phase component, in that case
there's no effect
on the radial value.
There's only an
effect on the angle.
And in that case, the
movement of the pole
is such that the radial
value stays the same.
But the angle of
the pole changes.
So in general, of
course, if a is complex,
the poles can have a
little movement that way
and also a little
movement that way.
In some cases, if
a is pure real,
the movement will
just be this way.
And if the magnitude
of a is equal to 1,
the movement of the pole
will just be that way.
All right, so we have first
of all, a list of properties.
But in particular,
there are two that we've
spent a little time on.
Finally, let's
look at, actually,
one example or one
and a half examples
to see how some
of the properties
might be useful in obtaining
the frequency response,
or the Z-transform of a system.
And the sequence that
I want to focus on
is a sequence that will
play an important role
throughout digital
signal processing
and in particular, in
some lectures coming up,
which is a sequence that I'll
refer to as a boxcar sequence.
It's the sequence which is
equal to unity for n between 0
and capital N minus 1.
And it's equal to 0 otherwise.
It's basically a
rectangular sequence.
0 for n negative, 0
for n greater than
or equal to capital N
and unity otherwise.
It's the counterpart of the
rectangular time function.
Well, there are a couple of
ways of getting at Z-transform.
Since we had some properties,
let's use one of them,
in particular, the
Shifting Property.
We can think of
a boxcar sequence
as the sum of two sequences.
One is a unit step.
And the second is the negative
of a unit step starting
at n equals capital
N to subtract off
these other values.
We can express x of n,
the boxcar sequence,
as a unit step minus a unit
step delayed by capital N.
Well, if you don't see this
graphical picture exactly,
you can just see quickly
that this is true
since for n greater than
or equal to capital N,
both of these arguments
are non-negative.
So the value of both of
these units steps is unity.
And they subtract off to zero.
All right, then to
get the Z-transform,
we can add the Z-transform
or this piece and this piece.
The Z-transform of a
unit step, well that's
our old friend a to the
n times a unit step,
except in this case, a equals 1.
So the Z-transform of this
piece is 1 over 1 minus z
to the minus 1.
This one is this one shifted.
So we can apply our Shifting
Property to multiply this by z
to the minus capital N, since
that's the amount of our shift,
so that this piece, then, has
a Z-transform z to the minus
n over 1 minus z to the minus 1.
Or if we add these two
together, we have 1 minus z
to the minus capital N divided
by 1 minus z to the minus 1.
Or we can rewrite that,
just to focus on something
a little more clearly,
multiplying top and bottom by z
to the n minus 1.
We can rewrite that
in this form so
that we have in the
numerator z to the capital
N minus 1, in the
denominator, this factor times
z to the minus 1.
Well, let's look at
the pole-zero pattern.
First of all, at z
equals 1, we have a pole.
So there's that pole.
Second of all, at z equals
0, we have n minus1 poles.
Well, let's stick in
the n minus 1 poles.
And let me just draw that with
an asterisk and an indication
that that's n minus 1 poles.
That's from that term.
And the zeros, well,
where are the zeros?
They're the roots of
the numerator, which
are at the N roots of unity.
Where are they?
They're distributed.
The N roots of unity
are distributed
around the unit circle
equally spaced in angle
starting at z equals 1.
So there's a zero at z equals 1.
But there's also a
pole it equals 1.
So in fact at z equals 1,
there's neither 0 nor a pole
because the two cancel out.
If we look at the
other zeros, then
let's take a specific
case, that is n equals 8.
We'd expect to see eight
zeros, except for the 1 at z
equals 1 that got canceled out.
So there are seven left--
one there, there, there,
there, here, here, and here.
Then, there was the
one at the origin.
Let me just indicate
that and the fact
that it got canceled
out by a pole.
So in fact, that
one isn't there.
So the pole-zero pattern
for the boxcar sequence,
then, is n minus 1
poles at the origin
plus zeros equally spaced
in angle, but with the 1
at z equals 1 missing.
Now, what does this mean
in terms of the frequency
response?
Well, we can very quickly
generate the frequency
response, or a rough idea
of the frequency response,
geometrically by referring
back to the set of ideas
that we introduced at the
beginning of the lecture
and ask what the behavior
of the pole-zero vectors
are as we go around
the unit circle.
The pole vectors, first of all,
introduce only a linear phase
term and have no effect
on the magnitude.
We had agreed on that before.
And so for the magnitude, we
only need focus on the zeros.
Well, one thing is
obvious and that
is that as we go
around the unit circle,
the frequency
response is obviously
0 when we hit each
one of these zeros.
That corresponds to pi over
4, pi over 2, pi over 2
plus pi over 4--
whatever that is,
pi, and the next increment
of pi over 4, et cetera.
Furthermore, you can see that
at least, it's not implausible.
Actually, we really could
argue this somewhat precisely,
that at omega equals 0,
that's the place where
we're the farthest away
from all the zeros.
As we start moving
around the unit circle,
if we're in-between
two of these zeros,
maybe we're a little farther
away from one of them,
but we're closer to another one.
And in terms of the product of
the length of the zero vectors,
that will tend to stay
smaller than the product
of the lengths of the zero
vectors at z equals 1.
Consequently, the frequency
response starts at some value
and of course, goes
down to 0 at pi over 4.
That's because of this 0.
Then, it comes back up
again, but not quite as far,
and then goes back
down to 0 at pi over 2.
Then it goes up again
and comes down again.
It goes up not quite as far.
And that's not particularly
obvious geometrically.
And then, the same thing
again going to 0 at pi.
And then of course as we come
back around the unit circle,
we see the same thing,
the same type of behavior,
repeated again.
So roughly, we can get
a geometric picture
of the frequency response
for a boxcar sequence
by looking at the
location of the poles
and zeros in the z-plane and
the behavior of the vectors
as we travel around
the unit circle.
Well finally, let's just
look at the Fourier transform
of the boxcar somewhat more
formally because in fact, it's
an important sequence.
And it's important to
have a fairly complete
precise statement of
the Fourier transform
and a complete picture
of what it looks like.
Well, let's see.
We had the Z-transform
as 1 minus z
to the minus n over 1
minus z to the minus 1.
Substituting in z
equals z to the j omega,
then we have x of e to
the j omega as this.
We can factor out a factor e
to the minus j omega capital
N over 2, leaving e to the j
omega capital N over 2 minus
e to the minus j omega capital
N over 2, and a denominator
factor e to the minus j omega
over 2 times e to the j omega--
over 2 minus e to the
minus j omega over 2.
This piece we recognize as 2j
sine omega capital N over to 2.
And this piece we recognize as
2-j times sine omega over 2.
And consequently, putting
these two terms together
and inserting this substitution,
the Fourier transform
is e to the minus j omega
capital N minus 1 over 2--
that's a linear phase
term, by the way--
times sine omega capital N over
2 divided by sine omega over 2.
And this function,
sine omega capital N
over 2 divided by
sine omega over 2,
is the discrete time
counterpart of what we usually
find in the continuous
time case as sine x over x.
That is, this is a sine nx
over sine x kind of function.
And it plays exactly the same
role in the discrete time case
that the sine x over x function
plays in the continuous time
case.
And that's not
unreasonable, actually,
because this arose by
looking at the Fourier
transform of a
rectangular sequence,
whereas the sine
x over x function
arises by looking at the Fourier
transform of a continuous time
rectangle.
So the sine nx over
sine x function,
which is what we have here,
is an extremely important
function-- as important as sine
x over x in the continuous time
case.
And consequently,
let me just show you
this function plotted out
a little more precisely
than I would be able
to do at the board.
In particular, let me show you
a viewgraph which illustrates
the function sine
omega capital N over 2
divided by sine omega over 2.
And I've sketched this now
over more than just a 0 to 2 pi
interval to, again, stress the
fact that this is periodic--
as all Fourier transforms are--
periodic with a period of 2 pi.
The important
characteristics of it--
some important characteristics.
There are a lot.
But some important
characteristics of it
are that it has an envelope.
It's basically a
sinusoidal function
with an envelope that is the
reciprocal of a sinusoid.
The period of this
sinusoid is from 0 to 2pi,
whereas this one wiggles
faster, depending
on the value of capital
N. I've sketched it here
for n equals 15.
But in fact, it has a
lot of the character
of a sine x over x function.
That is, it has a
big central lobe,
decays down and wiggles and
gets smaller as it's decaying.
But then, of course, the fact
that it has to be periodic
is what distinguishes
it in the discrete time
case from the sine x over x
function in the continuous time
case.
OK.
Well, this concludes our
discussion of the Z-transform.
We've now talked
about two transforms.
We've talked about
the Fourier transform
and the Z-transform spread
out over about five lectures.
And in the next lecture,
the next set of two or three
lectures, we'll be talking about
yet another transform, which
is a transform that's
really somewhat special
and linked very closely to
the notion of discrete time
signals and discrete
time signal processing.
That transform is the
Discrete Fourier transform.
And besides being a
mathematical tool,
as the Fourier transform and
the Z-transform have been,
Discrete Fourier transform has
some important computational
realizations and
computational implications
that will be one of the
important things that
will want to capitalize on
in applying digital signal
processing to real problems.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]